when I talk to people about doing the
future authoring program they often put
it off and it's not surprising because
it's hard and and be it but it's more
than that they think well I don't know
how to write I'm gonna do a bad job I
don't really like assignments I'm going
to have to do it perfectly I need to
wait till I have enough time and like
one of those is enough to stop you cold
and all five of them you're just done
and so I tell people do it haphazardly a
tiny bit at a time and badly because you
can do that I tell my students when
they're doing their thesis master's
thesis write a really bad first draft
and then we have a little conversation
about that because they don't think I
mean that because it sounds like a
cliche in some sense it's not a cliche
it's not a cliche at all it means you're
a terrible writer but but if someone put
a gun to your head and said you have to
have your hundred page thesis done by
next Monday or I'll shoot you but I
don't care how terrible it is you would
sit down and write it and the thing is
then you have it right then then you
have something and then you can fix it
you can iterate and fix it that bad
first draft that's the most valuable
thing and so that's what you need you
need a bad first draft of yourself and
there's there's an idea that young
developed about the trickster and the
Jester the comedian right that the
trickster is the precursor to the savior
that's one of the things I learned from
young it was just it's so unlikely you
never think that it's so amazing that
that might be the case but the the the
the the satirical in the ironic and and
the troublemaker that the comedian the
fool the fool is the precursor to the
savior why because you're a fool when
you start something new and so if you're
not willing to be a fool then you'll
never start anything new and if you
never start anything new that you won't
develop and so the willingness to be a
fool is the precursor to transformation
and that's the same as humility and so
if you're gonna write your destiny you
can do a bad first job you're gonna get
smarter as you move forward that's the
thing is that so something beckons to
you that's what happens here maybe the
star that Geppetto wished on was the
wrong damn star
but at least it was a star right at
least it was in the sky at least it
moved him forward and so you say in your
life well something grips you and and
and fills you with interest and you
think well should I do that and the
answer is if not that then something
what if it's a mistake it's a mistake
rest assured what do you know you're
gonna stumble around right and what's
gonna happen is this you're gonna move
to you're gonna not stay in stasis
you're not gonna wander around in
circles and I see people like that they
said well I never knew what to do and
now I'm 40 it's like that's not so good
that's not so good and you might say
well and there is a literature too that
suggests that people are a lot more
unhappy when they look back in their
lives about the things they didn't do
than they are about the mistakes they
made while they were doing things and so
that's really worth thinking about too
because there's redemptive mistakes and
a redemptive mistake would be a mistake
that you make when you go out and try to
do something and no you actually you
think okay I'm gonna try to do this and
you're not good at it you make a bunch
of mistakes it's like what's the
consequence if you pay attention is
you're not quite so stupid anymore
that's the thing is you've been informed
by your by the results of your errors
and so what happens is your you you
follow the beacon you follow the light
and and you're blind so you don't know
where the light is it's it's dimly
apprehended only and you're afraid to
follow it but you decide to take some
stumbling steps towards it and as you
take stumbling steps towards it you
become illuminated and enlightened and
informed because of the nature of your
experience because you're pushing
yourself beyond where you are and you're
going into the country that you have not
yet been in and you learn something and
so what happens then is the star moves
you move ten feet towards it you think
no that's not right I didn't get it
right it isn't there it's actually there
and so then you you see it somewhere
else and you shift yourself slightly and
you move forward and that's what happens
is that you continue as you change the
thing that guides you forward moves
right it's like God in the in the in the
desert in Egypt the pillar of
that you're following it's moving it's
not a permanent thing you move towards
it it moves away it guides you forward
and so you say well is what I'm aiming
at paradise itself and the answer to
that is no because what do you know you
could you couldn't see paradise if it
was right in front of you but you might
get a glimmer of it and so you move
towards it and you grow and then the
next time you open your eyes you see a
little bit more clearly and that's what
happens is that just happens over and
over right it keeps moving and so you
move like this but the thing that's so
cool is that
although zigs and zags you say in each
of those zags is it and zigs is a
catastrophe I hit a wall my god and then
I had to die a little bit and I barely
got back up it's a Phoenix
transformation at each at each turn and
it's painful but the thing is is that
even though you've you've traveled 20
miles let's say on that road and you've
only moved 3 miles forward you've moved
three miles forward instead of falling
backwards because that's the thing too
is that if you stand still you fall
backwards you cannot stand still because
the world moves away from you if you
stand still and there's no stasis
there's only backwards and so if you're
not moving fact we're back forwards then
you're moving backwards and that's more
more of the underlying truth of the
Matthieu principle to those who have
everything more will be given from those
who have nothing everything will be
taken it's a warning do not stay in one
place well as you Zig and zag maybe then
maybe the cataclysm of each
transformation starts to lessen there's
not so much of you that has to die with
every mistake and maybe you end up
oriented at least reasonably properly
and if you were sensible that would have
been your trip but it wasn't right it's
that and perhaps it's a lot worse than
that perhaps there's no shortage of
backtracking but it doesn't matter
because as you stumble forward you you
illuminate and inform yourself and
perhaps that's partly
the world is made of information and if
you encounter it and tangle with it then
it informs you and then you become
informed and then you're in formation
and then you're ready